la carga formal es un concepto muy
importante en la química orgánica y en
todos sus mecanismos y hay muchas formas
de calcular la forma
la carga formal y yo creo que esta es la
forma más sencilla la carga formal es
igual al número de electrones de
valencia de un átomo que normalmente se
encuentran en el átomo y de ese número
hay que restarle el número de electrones
presentes alrededor de ese mismo átomo
en su estructura de puntos ok entonces
vamos a ver algunos ejemplos sobre carga
fork o más bien de cómo calcular la
forma la carga formal que por ejemplo
está involucrado en el metano que y
entonces el metano tiene un átomo de
carbono con cuatro enlaces cuatro
enlaces conectados a hidrógeno es verdad
ahí tenemos nuestra molécula de metano y
voy a remarcar todavía más nuestros
electrones que se encuentran en los
enlaces covalentes muy bien ahí lo
tienen entonces nos preguntamos cuál es
la carga formal del carbono en esta
situación y el carbono se encuentra en
el grupo 4 de la tabla periódica
orgánica y entonces eso significa que el
número de electrones de valencia del
carbono en este caso sería 4 muy bien
entonces vamos a restar el número de
electrones presentes alrededor de este
átomo y lo que tenemos que recordar es
que en cada enlace covalente está
involucrado un átomo de hidrógeno que
podría representarse este digamos y un
átomo de carbono entonces en cada uno de
estos enlaces tenemos
un electrón perdón de carbono muy bien
entonces en este caso tenemos 4
electrones lo cual nos da una carga
formal de 0 así que el carbono tiene
carga formal 0 en este caso vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo que involucre carbono
en este en esta ocasión vamos a poner el
carbono pero únicamente con tres enlaces
muy bien vamos a poner solo tres enlaces
uniéndose con hidrógenos muy bien y voy
a pintar nuevamente los electrones para
que quede un poco más claro de qué es lo
que está ocurriendo muy bien entonces
nos preguntamos nuevamente cuál es la
carga formal del carbono en este caso
otra vez el carbono pues siempre va a
estar en la en el grupo 4 de la tabla
periódica orba orgánica así que tiene 4
electrones de valencia de perdón de
valencia en este caso muy bien
ahora vamos a restar el número de
electrones presentes alrededor del átomo
por cierto tú podrías estarte diciendo
oye pero pero esto como que no sigue
esencialmente la carga perdona la regla
del octeto verdad y es que en realidad
en realidad en este caso
la regla del octeto nos dice que máximo
puede tener 8 verdad entonces puede
tener menos lo único que sí
o más bien lo único que va a implicar en
este caso es que va a ser muy reactivo
va a tender a reaccionar fácilmente
verdad entonces ahora si nos preguntamos
cuántos electrones tiene este carbono
alrededor de él y podemos hacer más o
menos el mismo esquema de dibujar este
circuito y podemos encerrar sólo 3
electrones así que le restamos 3
electrones y esto nos da más 1 muy bien
entonces esto quiere decir que el
carbono tiene una carga positiva muy
bien y a los iones que tienen carga
positiva les llamamos cationes verdad en
este caso
el carbono bueno es un campo un camión
que involucra carbono verdad y por eso
es que lo conocemos como kart vocación
este es un cargo ocasión por ser un
camión que involucra carbono muy bien
cuál sería la forma de los átomos
alrededor de mi átomo de carbono en este
caso bueno podríamos calcular el número
estético que es igual vamos a ponerlo
número estético es igual al número de
enlaces con sigma más el número de pares
de electrones solitarios que tiene este
que este este átomo verdad entonces
tenemos aquí tres enlaces sigma y no hay
electrones
no hay electrones solitarios guardadas y
que nuestro número estético es
justamente 3 lo cual significa que el
carbono tiene una hibridación sp2 verdad
así que tenemos una hibridación sp2 de
este carbono muy bien lo cual lo cual
nos dice que tiene una geometría
triangular y plana verdad es decir si
nosotros dibujamos un plano aquí en el
espacio de tres dimensiones este digamos
como una hoja de papel
podríamos podríamos pintar el carbono
aquí y los tres hidrógenos se encuentran
en la misma hoja de papel verdad y más o
menos ahí más o menos lo tiene ok
además si tiene una hibridación sp2
tiene un orbital p libre verdad así que
sabemos de los vídeos que ya hemos hecho
sobre hibridación sp2 que tenemos un
orbital vamos a pintarlo con azul
tenemos un orbital p libre aquí verdad
digamos algo así se ve muy bien entonces
ahí tienen más o menos la geometría que
tiene este está esta molécula vamos a
ver otro ejemplo vamos a ver otro
ejemplo ahora qué tal que tenemos el
mismo en caso digamos el carbono con
tres enlaces tenemos tres enlaces pero
en este caso vamos a pintar un par de
electrones aquí estamos completando la
regla del octeto muy bien entonces misma
pregunta cuál es la carga formal del
carbono en este caso pues como se
encuentra en el grupo 4 tiene 4
electrones de valencia y le restamos el
número de electrones presentes alrededor
verdad entonces si nos damos cuenta éste
tiene 1
3 y estos dos que están digamos
solitarios pues nos dan 5 electrones
entonces restamos 5 electrones y esto
nos da una carga formal de menos 1
quiere decir que este corresponde al
caso en que es un un unión verdad es un
millón negativo y como involucra carbono
pues entonces se le llama carbunión ok
uno podría pensar bueno es carbón pero
pues no queremos contar dos vocales así
que lo dejamos como carbunión y ahora
cuál sería la la geometría de este
carbón pues nuevamente si calculamos el
número estético sería sería el número de
enlaces y gmac que tenemos que son tres
más el número de pares de electrones
solitarios que tenemos entonces tenemos
un par solitario que es entonces tenemos
que sumar uno lo cual nos da cuatro el
número estético es cuatro y por lo tanto
podemos concluir que el carbono tiene
una hibridación sp3 y esto se exhibe en
una geometría piramidal
vamos ahora a calcular la carga formal
para un átomo de nitrógeno así que
vámonos adelante y vamos a aplicar
digamos vamos a aplicar todo lo que ya
hemos estado viendo ok entonces ahora
tenemos un átomo de nitrógeno vamos a
poner un átomo de nitrógeno que está
unido a dos hidrógenos aquí vamos a
pintar sus electrones tenemos dos
hidrógenos y vamos a poner acá arriba
sus dos pares de electrones solitarios
muy bien entonces la pregunta es cuál es
la carga formal de este átomo de
nitrógeno y el nitrógeno se encuentra en
el grupo 5 de la tabla periódica
orgánica así que tenemos 5 electrones de
valencia y vamos a restarle el número de
electrones presentes alrededor del átomo
que son 2 456 entonces tenemos una carga
de menos 1 ok entonces tenemos aquí
justamente 1
a nyon verdad tenemos una unión así que
como te podrás estar dando cuenta es muy
muy útil ser capaces de calcular esta
carga formal y mientras más calculas más
fácil podrás reconocer este tipo de
patrón así no vas a tener que
involucrarse en todas las matemáticas
nunca más así que dos pares y dos pares
solitarios y dos enlaces provocarían una
carga formal negativa verdad ahora qué
tal que tenemos tres enlaces con este
átomo de hidrógeno de nitrógeno perdón
tenemos este átomo de nitrógeno con tres
enlaces
a tres hidrógenos muy bien entonces
pintamos los electrones y misma pregunta
cuál es la carga formal del nitrógeno si
es que éste tiene sus dos o su par de
electrones sacaron muy bien entonces el
número de electrones de valencia que
tiene el nitrógeno en 5 y restamos el
número de electrones que estén alrededor
que son tres más dos son cinco entonces
éste tiene una carga formal cero en el
siguiente caso
si tenemos un nitrógeno unido a cuatro
hidrógenos tenemos una unión a cuatro
hidrógenos en este caso cuántos a
cuantos electrones tenemos alrededor
pues alrededor tenemos cuatro electrones
verdad tenemos cuatro electrones y el
número de electrones de valencia del
nitrógeno son cinco entonces restamos
cinco menos cuatro esto nos da 1 lo cual
nos dice que este es un camión tiene una
carga positiva vamos a ver un ejemplo
más complicado qué
al menos que podría parecer más
intimidante por ejemplo qué tal que
tenemos una especie de anillo de esta
forma
un anillo de esta forma tenemos un
enlace doble aquí un nitrógeno unido a
un hidrógeno también ni por supuesto
ponemos dos o un par de electrones muy
bien entonces nuevamente pues el número
de electrones de valencia del nitrógeno
son 5 y restamos el número de electrones
presentes alrededor que de cada enlace
podemos sacar uno y tenemos otros dos
aquí solitarios eso quiere decir que
tenemos 5 y por lo tanto nos da una
carga formal 0 ahora vamos a hacer un
ejemplo contrario vamos a suponer que
tengo digamos algo así tengo digamos más
o menos la misma figura si te das cuenta
no es tan apabullante ya que hace es un
ejemplo verdad tenemos algo así tenemos
esta molécula y ahora suponemos que nos
dan la carga formal ahora nos dan la
carga formal y nos preguntamos cuántos
electrones libres hay alrededor
y la razón por la cual vas a ver esto
muchas ocasiones es porque los químicos
usualmente dejan digamos los pares de
electrones solitarios y solo dibujan la
carga formal es decir no no pintan los
electrones ok entonces es un poco más
rápido hacer hacerlo de esta forma y
veremos que si podemos descubrir cuántos
pares solitarios de electrones hay
alrededor del nitrógeno pues entonces
solo necesitamos esta información de la
carga forma lo que entonces la primera
forma de hacerlo y que realmente es muy
fácil sería por ejemplo tenemos algo así
si si pinto nuevamente esta molécula
pero con sus enlaces verdad entonces la
forma fácil de hacerlo sería decir bueno
el nitrógeno dado que está en el segundo
periodo debe tener un octeto bordalás y
que tiene dos enlaces unidos a este
nitrógeno verdad entonces debe estar
rodeado de cuatro electrones verdad eso
nos deja en
los pares para que tenga un total de 8
así que tenemos 8 electrones alrededor
del nitrógeno y entonces podríamos
calcular la carga formal muy muy muy
fácilmente verdad y simplemente ya
tenemos la respuesta otra forma de
resolver esto es utilizando primero la
carga formal si tenemos digamos esto
aquí el nitrógeno y el hidrógeno
entonces nosotros sabemos que tenemos 5
electrones de valencia normalmente pero
si éste tiene una carga negativa quiere
decir que hay un electrón extra verdad
entonces tenemos alrededor del átomo de
nitrógeno 6 electrones ok entonces esto
nos da que si aquí tenemos 2 electrones
nos hacen falta otros 4 eso nos da dos
pares de electrones libres así que
obtuvimos la respuesta de ambas formas
verdad de cual ya sea haciendo el octeto
o cálculo haciendo una unas pequeñas
cuentas matemáticas y esto
una habilidad importante que hay que
desarrollar también y en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a hacer un poquito más de
ejercicio sobrecarga formal